your forearms contain flexor muscles
that allow you to bend your fingers
long cord-like structures called tendons
connect these muscles to the bones in
your fingers and thumb
a tunnel of tissue called a tendon
sheath
surrounds each tendon this allows the
tendon to glide smoothly
as the fingers move the sheath is held
in place by bands of tissue called
pulleys they hold the tendon close to
the bone for optimal functioning of the
tendon
when your flexor muscles contract the
pulleys help
guide the tendons to flex or bend your
fingers
normally the tendons glide smoothly
through the pulleys when the fingers
flex and extend
trigger finger also known as trigger
thumb
or stenosing tenosynovitis is a
condition where the pulley at the base
of your finger
becomes inflamed and swollen
this makes it harder for the tendon to
move through the pulley
over time the tendon may also swell and
form a bump near the pulley
when you bend your finger the swollen
area on the tendon may cause a catching
or triggering sensation as it initially
gets hung on the pulley
and then slips underneath if not treated
the tendon may swell enough that it
cannot pass beneath the pulley
as a result your finger may get stuck in
a bent position
if you have trigger finger you may have
one or more of the following symptoms
a tender lump on your palm at the base
of your finger
a catching popping or locking sensation
when you move your finger
and pain when you bend or straighten
your finger
the cause of trigger finger isn't known
but
some conditions that can increase your
risk for it include
diabetes rheumatoid arthritis
gout and repeated injuries
forceful and repetitive hand gripping
may also increase your risk
to treat mild trigger finger your doctor
may advise you to rest your hand
and avoid activities that make it worse
your doctor may prescribe
anti-inflammatory medication
or a corticosteroid injection to reduce
the swelling
you may also need to wear a finger
splint to keep your fingers straight
if non-surgical treatments haven't
worked your doctor may advise you to
have a surgical procedure
to start the procedure your surgeon will
make a small incision
in your palm then the pulley will be cut
to free the tendon
at the end of the procedure your
incision may be closed with stitches
and covered with a soft bandage
to find out more about trigger finger
talk to your healthcare provider